Oh No essentially 1/2 my third box on a
perfect nation and robustness so just to
remind everybody this is uh you know
we're looking forward in this workshop
where the commands no bunch of things
that still need to be worked out so
that's
[Music]
okay thank you everyone for being here
and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me so what I'm gonna do today
is share with you a little bit about
what's happening in the world of
verification formal verification or deep
learning systems and I have to start out
by professing that I'm not a machine
learning person not centrally from the
ml community I'm also not traditional
theoretical computer science person and
so what I'd like to do today is share
some of the the work that's going on in
a different community which is the
formal methods world and at the end I
want to be able to bring up a few
directions and questions that I think
would benefit the area of verification
for deep learning systems and I think
the community working on theory of deep
learning would be that the right people
- okay so and I'm going to present today
a selection of work so rather than going
deep into any one contribution I'm going
to give you a more of a overview of a
few different topics and this is work
done with several excellent students and
postdocs and colleagues okay so the
context here is that as we all know
there's a growing use of machine
learning and particularly deep learning
in safety critical systems of all kinds
and autonomous vehicles self-driving
cars are a good example of this and you
know as we see more and more deployment
of deep learning in these systems
there's also growing concerns about
safety and as we all know there's
numerous papers showing us showing that
you know deep neural networks can be
easily fooled and there's also been
serious accidents involving potentially
the failure of perception systems used
for object detection and classification
and and as we know deep learning is has
been extremely effective in perceptual
tasks and there's a good chance that
deep learning was involved in some of
these so the particular angle with
I come at this problem of ensuring
safety and higher levels of assurance is
from the area of formal methods now I
know that not all of you may be familiar
with this field so let me just introduce
what it is so the field of formal
methods is really at the core about
computational proving so it's about
algorithms used to prove theorems and
primarily these theorem proving
techniques are used for modeling
mathematical modeling design and
analysis of systems and primarily in
formal methods you can think of the the
tasks that we do as falling into one of
three categories so there's the task of
specification formal specification which
is writing down mathematically what the
system must do or must not do
then there's the verification task which
is once you have a spec and then you
have a system description you're
essentially trying to understand why
whether or why the system meets the spec
so for instance if a system does not
make the specification we really would
like to get a counterexample or error
trace that explains to us why it goes
wrong and then the holy grail in formal
methods is to do correct by construction
synthesis which is you start with a
high-level specification and you'd like
to be able to automatically generate an
implementation that is probably correct
and we've seen in many different domains
that as there is a need for higher
levels of assurance there's increasing
interest in formal methods a
particularly good success story for
formal methods is that of digital
circuit design or processor design where
today pretty much every digital circuit
or microprocessor that is taped out goes
through some levels of formal methods
along the way and so in the context of
this Simon's program and this workshop
we're looking at deep learning systems
and by this I mean not only deep neural
networks but also the systems that use
deep neural networks as components and
what we are interested in doing is
trying to address
the design challenges of these systems
so a few years ago we try to understand
from a formal methods perspective what
are the the special challenges that AI
based systems particularly deep learning
systems bring for formal verification
and so what I'd like to do in this slide
is walk you through that to give you an
idea of what we think are the challenges
from the formal methods perspective and
then I will what you see here on this
slide is the typical picture of formal
verification so what happens is you
start out on the left with three inputs
so you need a model of the system under
verification yes you need a model of its
operating environment E and then you
need the specification of the properties
that the system was satisfying and then
inside the box the we need a decision
procedure that can answer this question
which is when you put together s and E
so you take the system and you compose
it with operating environment does it
satisfy the specification Phi okay and
then you would like to have a yes or no
output so either it says yes indeed it
satisfies the specification and here's a
proof or no it does not and here's one
or more counter examples showing how
things can go wrong okay and in formal
methods there's been quite a lot of work
expended on how do you solve these
decision problems for particular classes
of se and Phi now typically Phi tends to
be specified in some logic but people
have also used objective functions and
one of the most effective use cases of
formal methods is in finding counter
examples and finally this corner case
situations that lead to safety
violations okay so so now when we look
at deep learning systems and I'm going
to use throughout this talk I'm going to
use autonomous vehicles and the use of
deep learning and autonomous vehicles as
a way to make things more concrete there
are certain specific challenges that
arise so for instance in the case of
autonomous vehicles it's incredibly
challenging to model the operating
environment of a vehicle for the most
part unlike this is unlike things like
digital circuits or software we don't
really know what are all the agents in
the environment let alone have good
models for how they behave and that's
that's going to be the one of the first
challenges for formal methods the second
aspect of this is that now if you wanted
to do verification of these systems we
have to be able to deal with these large
complex ml models like deep neural
networks which are a very different
beast when we think about the tools the
computational tools used in formal
methods and then a further challenge is
that especially in deep learning one of
the most effective uses of deep learning
is in perception but there is no formal
specification for a perceptual task like
you know take a image and recognize
whether there's a car in it or not right
and so if you look at the little picture
down there that is actually a real car
but it's dressed up to look like a snail
or a bug right and so what's you know
how would you formally specify what it
means to be a car right seems like this
is an impossible task and so that you
know even coming up with the inputs is a
challenge for formal methods and then
you know after that we have all the
other traditional problems which is now
we have to search extremely high
dimensional input in state spaces
extremes of images which are you know
much more higher dimensional than the
traditional kinds of systems that
problem ëthis has been applied to and
then if you want to do correct by
construction it's not at all clear where
to start all right so seems like an
incredibly challenging domain and I
think it's in a way it's good because
there's enough problems here for the
community to work on for for at least a
decade if not more now I want to zoom in
on what I'm going to talk about in this
particular talk okay and the main
message here I want to convey is that at
least for verification or for verified
deep learning system
the context in which the ml model is
used matters a great deal okay and so
the picture I'd like you to have for
this talk is the one right here where
we're really looking at the combination
of the system under verification with
the environment and it's important to
model the environment okay so the deep
learning the deep neural network is one
component of that system but it's not
the only thing and there's a number of
reasons why modeling the context of the
deep neural network is important so the
first is that usually when we design
these systems like an autonomous vehicle
what you have are these you know top
level system level requirements on
safety that don't necessarily translate
directly to the traditional notions of
robustness that we often look at for
deep neural networks okay what we want
to be able to do is start with the
system level requirements and make sure
that those are guaranteed and so that
connection between the system level
requirements and things you prove about
the neural network I think is is yet to
be made the second is that we for
adversarial analysis we want to be able
to model realistic environments in
adversaries and I think the more needs
to be done to understand what what
realistic means okay a third use case
for modeling the environment is that
it's actually useful to to scale up
verification okay so if you look at the
neural network that's processing images
the the input is extremely high
dimensional but if you model the
environment you may realize that
actually there's a much lower
dimensional environment state space that
is generating those images and by
modeling the environment you can
actually reduce the search over from you
know from the high dimensional space
down to the this the the latent lower
dimensional space that comes from the
environment model and then finally I
think it's important to for any
engineering design to be able to
understand what the assumptions are that
the system is making about its
environment and and so you know creating
an environment model is a good start for
that
okay so in this in the rest of this talk
I'm going to be looking primarily a deep
learning for perception and looking at
this in the context of what I called a
cyber-physical system so things like
autonomous vehicles which are
combinations of computational systems
and physical systems so an example I'll
use again and again in this talk is an
automatic emergency braking system that
uses deep learning for perception and
this is what it looks like so imagine
you have a card and it has a camera in
front that's facing out towards the road
let's also assume that this car is
operating in an extremely simple
environment so it's you see that picture
up there it's the straight road in the
desert where there's there could just be
one car in front okay one lane in each
direction and so the camera captures
this image that goes into a deep neural
network the job of the deep neural
network is simply to do a binary
classification of whether there is a car
in front or not okay so in the car or no
car that goes into a controller the
controller then sends its control input
to the vehicle which will in control
theory parlance we call the plant which
then interacts with the environment and
that produces new sensor data so we're
looking at this closed-loop model and
and then the goal of the ABS system is
if there is a car in front then it
should start actuate the brakes in a
certain prescribed order okay I'm going
to hide the details of how the
controller works but the basic idea is
when an obstacle is near the ABS system
to start activating the brakes so as to
maintain a certain minimum safety
distance over the the two or three years
that we've used this example we've
created multiple models in various
simulators and in our papers we have
links to all of those but in particular
we've been using you know real neural
networks for object detection and
classification in particular I'll be
using the squeeze dead system that's
been developed here at Berkeley in in
much of this talk okay so with that in
mind
let me start off by talking about
specification first right so if I take a
deep learning based system what are the
properties that we must verify so the
way I think about this is there's two
kinds of properties here there are those
that you write at the system level which
is the entire ABS system right so yeah
it's not focusing on the noodle network
but looking at the system that contains
that and and what we find here is that
the kinds of properties we see there are
the typical properties that you write
for these cyber-physical systems so you
have safety liveness stability these
sort of things but at the component
level which is at the neural network
level there's quite a range of
properties when what people can write
and so robustness seems to be the most
popular type of property people talk
about and there's a few variants there
and I'll spend a few more slides to talk
about robustness but there's also other
kinds of properties people are
interested in like input output
relations so if the input lies in a
certain region you want the output to
lie in a certain other region there's
also things like monotonicity fairness
constraints certain coverage goals with
respect to whether neurons fire or not
properties like semantic invariance that
the output should be invariant to
certain transformations on the input and
distributional assumptions and so on so
in this talk I'm not going to go through
all of these and just going to focus on
on system level properties and on
robustness but if you're interested we
have a paper that that describes this
range of properties for deep neural
networks okay so so robustness to
adversarial inputs of mutations has seen
a lot of attention right and so is the
kind of thing that I think we're all
familiar with is you have an input and
you add make a mutation to that and and
the mutated input produces an answer
that is wrong okay now there's a it's
quite a range of definitions of what
robustness what two adversarial in
inputs means and so one of the things we
did several months ago is try to survey
all the different variants of robustness
and then give a
man way to write down these local
robustness properties okay and so let me
walk you through that okay so the engine
in general in local robustness you're
given an input X so from capital X the
input space
and what you want to do is find another
input X star such that three constraints
are satisfied so the first one the first
constraint is what we call it
admissibility constraint and so the idea
here is that you want X star to lie in
the subset of capital X we call X tilde
okay so this defines the valid set of
perturbations of allowed perturbations
the second constraint is what we call a
distance constraint which says that you
can you know even with an X tilde you're
only interested in perturbations that
are within a specified distance away
from the original input and then the
third constraint which we'll call the
target behavior constraint is really the
goal of the adversary right what the
adversary wants to do here okay and so
this is a decision formulation of the
robustness property typically in the
literature what we found is people tend
to write optimization versions of this
and this broadly speaking two variants
there one is the one where you want to
minimize the perturbation so you in this
case you want to find the closest x star
to cap to X that causes something to go
wrong okay
and so in this case you can say well you
know your your mu is your is your
distance metric between X and x star and
you're going to bound that by some
parameter alpha and then you want to
minimize alpha the other one is you want
to maximize some notion of loss right
and so in this case this is more about
something in the target behavior
constraint so you have this loss
function and you want to be able to max
my speedo okay yeah you try to to
understand the need for one mainly white
people that we defined as the point sex
target satisfied - okay so one of the
things we wanted to do is not to keep
the admissibility constraint separate
from a notion of similarity to the
original input right so there are cases
where you want to define the the space
of modified inputs not as being
dependent on on X but as being from some
you know space of allowed perturbations
right and so it's just but you're right
you could actually merge them but we
just felt for in this sake of
understanding the literature it it helps
to separate them out okay so so this
helps us capture all the local
robustness properties but one of the
things that we when doing this exercise
we felt is that there are certain things
that local robustness doesn't quite
capture right there are certain
questions that remain okay so for
instance you can define these mutations
as being norm bound right so close to
some to the original input but first of
all you know can these mutations
actually occur in in practice in the
environment okay so I I'm I'm if I'm
looking at the deep learning system in
context then can the environment
actually produce these sorts of
mutations secondly there could be
mutations that the environment can
produce that are big in the sense that
that the X star is actually quite far
away from X in in the pixel space but in
some semantic sense it's not so far away
so an example of this is if I have an
image with cars in them and I go and
change the colors of all the cars right
so now I'm making the transformations to
a whole bunch of pixels but I'm not
really changing the semantics of the
image with respect to say object
detection and classification right and I
saw you know I still want my
network to to produce the same output
wait on this transformation the third
question is well even if there was like
an adversarial prohibition what's the
impact at the system level of that so
let's look at the first two questions so
so this is what my my collaborator so
Misha and I called semantic adversarial
analysis that we really need to be able
to look at doing adversarial
perturbations not on the concrete input
space but on what we'll call the
semantic feature space which is what
produces the concrete input so the
picture here is that there is a space s
which we think of as modeling the
environment and then there's a process
of rendering right that produces
concrete inputs and what I'm really
interested in in is a notion of semantic
robustness which is that if I take two
semantic feature vectors s and s prime
and these are things like the the
positions of cars the models the the
color maybe the time of day the position
of the light source things like that
those are your semantic features and I
take two semantic feature vectors that
are close to each other okay and and now
if I look at the X and X prime that are
generated from s and s prime I want the
output of the neural network to be close
on those
yes so the render so whatever takes the
parameters of your semantic feature
space and then produces an image from
that okay so so that's what I want I
want I want something that can do
semantic robustness analysis okay now if
I look at this pipeline up here I you
know if the renderer are is
differentiable then I should be able to
apply all the techniques from standard
adversarial analysis to this and
basically be able to find adversarial
inputs in the s space of course you know
differentiable rendering is is a hard
problem that many groups are working on
but there's been some recent progress on
that topic and so very recently so miss
John I along with our students got some
results where we took the the 3d sdn
differentiable renderer that came out of
MIT recently and what we did was if you
look at the image on the top you can see
the the bounding boxes on the cars over
there and so what we've done to produce
the image the adversarial input image
down here is we've applied the fast
gradient sine method so standard
admissible enhances technique but on the
semantic feature space which is modeling
this scene and what you see of course is
that we change the color of the red car
and then we've also changed the time of
day so some of the shadowing effects and
so forth are different and what you see
here is that now it misses this car
entirely so there's no bounding box
around this one where there was one up
there okay so you know the hope is as as
progress and differentiable rendering
and things like that get better will be
able to take everything that we have
done in admission analysis over the
concrete space and being a be up to be
able to do things like this
as changing the color means it uses
right changing the color of this vehicle
and also changing the time of day I
think those are two things I can't
remember maybe the texture of some of
the I don't understand either right so
this is some of the I mean this is just
telling us that we were able to find
this sort of adversarial input and I
think this is a realistic transformation
right on the scene space but but now the
question is why did this happen well the
neural network missed this and I don't
understand that okay so you know if if
there are people in the audience who can
help us understand this that would I
would love to chat with you okay I have
another example coming up later in the
talk which is or has a very similar
nature but the what the equation you had
in the previous slide yeah the property
effectively says that if you have things
that are close in semantic space you
want the predictions of the network to
be similar that's right the projection
is how do you capture that on the one
hand first of all how do you capture
semantically similar yes and second you
could of course train the the networks
in a semi-supervised running way to to
to analog that when s is similar to s
prime then f of X needs to be similar
yes yeah so I I was the network trained
with any of these semi-supervised losses
no consideration so the answer is no it
was not trained with the semi-supervised
losses after your first question what is
the notion of similarity right we were
just using a standard norm bound but in
the semantic feature space
I think it's very hard because some
changes are not small in RGB space yeah
so what what is gonna be the feature
space in which those changes are small I
don't have a good answer to that right
so yeah I mean I think it's a it's it's
an open problem yet to figure out what
are good notions of similarity in the
somatic feature space go back to the
cars EPS I'm nitpicking your example but
admittedly if our goal is to try to
understand why they never failed bottom
unit should not have a gray car that is
not a recolored red car turn into gray
if you look closely there are all sorts
of significant distortions in the back
of the yard so I'm not saying that maybe
of course the perfect deep network would
identify you know this prettier example
is not purely a recovering yeah that's
true but I have so this is from the
virtual key data set right and the top
image is also is not an original image
it's a rear end 'red so it actually has
it's gone through like an identity
transformation through the film European
renderer okay so and the reason is that
the renderer does produce artifacts as
you see right and so we try to be as you
know equal with respect to those as we
could
so I have a big problem with all this
approach yes because on one hand to
produce synthetic examples of which the
network fails and there is no way to say
that these are something that we should
be really worried about or is this just
an artifact of the way you generate
adversarial examples so this is on one
hand on the other hand even if you said
if you show that there is no such
problems you say nothing about real
problems that you would encounter in
practice because maybe there is
something that is not generated by your
model yes so what exactly do you verify
okay excellent question and so I think
this is a great segue into what I'll
talk about next so hopefully that'll
answer that in the interest of time let
me move on and I'm happy to take other
questions later so the question really
that came up in this last one is you
know why do I care what's them the
impact of an adversarial input on the
system right and so really I think what
I showed you was that hey we need to go
from standard notion of robustness to a
somatic notion of robustness but even
that is not enough right and what I
really care about is verifying this
system level specification so I'm going
to take something very simple here so
what I'm really interested in is
verifying the system containing the deep
neural network so go to go back to my
example that's the closed loop system
and I'm going to just write properties
of that system in standard notation
that's used in in verification so we use
often a notation called temporal logic
and so what that expression says is that
it's always the case at all time points
the distance between the ego vehicle
autonomous vehicle and any environment
object is at least some threshold Delta
and the key point here with this
property is that it is not over the deep
neural network it's not a property over
the X and y we input an output of the
look it's about it's over the the other
parts of the model which we have
well-defined mathematical models for
okay and so so here's that closed loop
model right
s-e is the state of the environment X is
the image that's the input to the neural
network F Y is the output the control
input is U and the plant state is s of B
and that same property is of the
following form so it's for all time
points t and the state of the in what
environment state of the plant all of
these are functions of time and now I
have the safety predicate which in the
previous slide was that the distance
should be at least Delta right so I have
the safety predicate that should hold at
all time points ok that's the kind of
property that I'm gonna verify now this
the kind of property we have is a fairly
standard property for verification the
new challenge posed by the use of deep
learning is that typically in order to
do verification you have to do what is
called symbolic evaluation because you
are trying to verify for all inputs for
all X right and so what you want to be
able to do is be able to evaluate F for
all possible x and symbolic evaluation
of these deep neural networks is just
not computationally feasible at this
point so so the question is how do you
actually get verification to scale up ok
and in the work that we've been doing
we've been applying fairly standard
principles from the verification
literature so the first idea is
abstraction which is we're going to try
to replace the deep neural network by a
simpler approximation and then do the
analysis with that approximation and
then use those results to be able to say
something about the original system and
the second is what we call as
compositional reasoning which is you'll
break things up into components and try
to break up the verification task into
into component so in the cyber physical
systems world we know how to verify
safety properties of these kinds of
systems ok so the difference between
this picture and the one I showed you
before is there is no sensor that's
capturing images and there's no deep
neural network right you directly have
the environment state fair into the
controller alright and so it would be
great if we could take our more complex
verification problem and reduce
to solving one or more of these ok then
we can just use as a subroutine all the
work that's happened already in the
verification world and so this is how we
do it we start with what I call the CPS
ml model so this is like the closed-loop
model with the deep neural network in it
and the property v and the first step we
do is we abstract the deep neural
network away from the model and we
started with something very simple ok so
what we do is we replace the noodle
network with with two approximations ok
one we call an over approximation and
the other we call it under approximation
the idea here is that an over
approximation is something that is like
a conservative assumption so in
particular the most conservative
assumption you can make about the
network about its behavior is that it's
always wrong ok
note that in this case we actually have
a model of the environment so we know
what ground truth is right so if there
is a car in the image right the
environment model would say that and so
in the over approximate case that the
idea is that if your environment model
says that there's a car in front of the
camera you're your approximation of the
noodle Network will say no there's no
car right so it's always giving you the
wrong answer the under approximate one
is is the perfect classifier so it knows
exactly what the ground truth is and it
always outputs that ok now the true
behavior of the of the noodle Network is
somewhere in between but by by looking
at these two extremes what we're able to
do is compute what I call the region of
uncertainty ok so this is basically a
predicate over the state of the
environment and the state of the vehicle
and the control inputs that tells you
you know if these are the values of s
ESP and you and the the decision of the
ML model flipped from being wrong to
being being correct to being wrong then
my safety property would be violated
right so it's really telling you what's
the the the the the the states in which
the decision of the the ML model matters
and what we do there is we take that and
then we project that to the ML feature
space so we try to find out here's the
region of input
to the the noodle network that
correspond to this region of uncertainty
and then we can invoke our favorite
adversarial analysis technique but now
only focusing on this subset of input
space okay and we can produce
misclassifications which we then combine
with analysis of rest of the system to
produce full system counter examples
okay if at this point we find a counter
example we can out output it but if we
don't then we have to go through a step
of what's called refinement which is
basically going from our you know highly
approximate this over approximate and
approximate models to something that's
that's more realistic and in between
okay so let me give you an example more
concretely or what happens here so this
is going back to the ABS example so in
this very simple case the two state
variables we will look at are the
initial relative velocity between the
ego vehicle and an environment vehicle
and that's on the x-axis and the initial
Verret of distance between the ego
vehicle environment vehicle that's on
the y-axis and what you're seeing here
the colors is that everything in the
green region are combinations of initial
relative velocity initial relative
distance where the safety property holds
for a certain period of time and
everything in the red region are
combinations where the safety property
is violated okay so that means it gets
within the minimum safety distance and
this particular picture that you see
here is for the case where the ML model
is perfect so it's always giving you the
correct round to the answer okay and so
in particular you have these red regions
which are cases where the initial
relative velocity is in this case very
high and the initial relative distance
is quite low and so it doesn't matter
what the if the classifier is correct
you are too close to the environment
vehicle to avoid a collision
okay now we do the same thing for the
case where we have the pessimistic ml
model so the thing that where it's
always wrong and you see that more of
the green turns into red
and so now what we're interested in
doing is taking a difference between
these two pictures and so that's the
yellow region okay so using existing
verification techniques we can actually
compute these regions and so we can take
the difference between these two and and
that's basically all combinations of
initial relative distance and relative
velocity that where if the ml model
produced a miss classification that
could lead to an unsafe and so what we
do there is we take those combinations
and then we concretize them by producing
images that correspond to those alright
so that's the idea you're taking these
models where you've abstracted away the
ml model right and then we apply our
traditional verification techniques to
compute these regions and then once
we've computed the regions we can go
back and say okay now what is the the
feature space that we need to focus on
which one to the left the leftmost yeah
so that's this ground truth right that's
just like you're specifying the
requirement yes how did we get this but
it depends on the dynamics of the the
vehicles and the in your model right so
it depends not just so so what what
we're seeing here is anything in the red
region here is basically yeah why is it
not smooth okay I think it's just an
artifact of the way it's it's computed
and plotted
okay so so what can we do with this so
once we are able to compute this yellow
region and then produce these images
what we can do is do a search a more
systematic search over that the space of
all images corresponding to the yellow
region and that's what you're seeing on
this slide and so in particular there's
three dimensions along which we generate
images there so one is what we call the
X dimension which is the lateral
dimension here of moving an environment
car along the direction perpendicular to
the road direction the Z is you know
along the road direction towards the
camera or away from the camera and this
axis is the bright is the brightness of
the image so to keep things simple we
have three axis of modifications so you
can think of these are all modifications
to the semantic feature space and what
we find here is that maybe you know
according to intuition as we increase
the brightness of the image or as we
move the environment car away from the
camera the number of misclassifications
increases and indeed you get images like
this which on the screen is really hard
to see but there's you know there's an
environment car way over there and it's
a very bright image but what we also
find are things like this so it may be
hard to see in the back but there is one
miss classification here in in a sea of
correct correctly classified images and
this turns out to be the following image
where there's a car that's slightly
driving on the wrong side of the road
but close enough to the the ego vehicle
that if it's missed it would lead to a
collision
so see the other billion seems into
speculation won't test but I'm guessing
this is not possible to do an exhaustive
search in that region right any question
they hoping that some points are you
pick up think is it an exhaustive search
in that region or is it illegal right so
so that region is the continuous region
right and so in practice what you have
to do is you you have to grid up that
region with a fine enough grid and then
we do an exhaustive search over that
grid if you wanted to do a search over
the continuous region then we need you
know symbolic techniques that can do
that and as of now at least for the
kinds of dynamical models we have those
techniques to escape
all right so so that that was actually
one of her first results from for more
than two years ago and then we were able
to extend the same technique to streams
of images so so here it's the same kind
of situation so you see here on this
road there's green dots and red dots and
every dot is a location where an
environment car is placed and the red
dots are cars that are missed and the
green dots are cars that are correctly
detected and and we found in particular
this is using squeezed debt which is
trained on the key data set and we find
alarmingly lots of cases where the it
misses cars that are close to the ego
vehicle and then we can confirm that in
the closed loop simulation those could
lead to an unsafe State okay so the idea
here is now being able to because of
using abstraction we can sidestep this
challenge of searching this high
dimensional space by instead doing our
analysis on the abstract models and then
and then you know use a separate abyssal
analysis technique to search through the
image space efficiently
okay well the next steps obviously is if
you can generate lots of counter
examples then we'd like to be able to
use them to retrain the neural network
so this is very similar to the work and
adversely analysis where you can use
those adversarial examples to retrain
them the one difference between this
work and the work and a bacilli analysis
is that here the examples that we are
adding back into the data set are using
to augment read a set are those that
violate the safety specification at the
system level so they are not really
examples that violate local robustness
right but instead they're their counter
examples to safety and what we've seen
is that by being careful about which of
these counter examples you add back to
the training set you can substantially
increase the accuracy of your ml model
and you can also retrain until you don't
see any safety violations
[Music]
so so with respect to that bullet what
we do is use measures that the object
detection literature commonly uses so
here we start with an existing data set
right and we are a measuring accuracy
using mean average precision and other
metrics and what we are showing here is
by adding back counter example images
were able to improve accuracy with
respect to those metrics yeah so this is
so this is empirical right so this is
you over the empirical data set right so
so there is a with respect to bullet
number three there's a disconnect from
what I talked about earlier which is
when it's not based on the environment
model but bullet number four in this is
really the case where we do have an
environment model and we are retraining
okay so let me conclude very quickly the
other thing that we've been doing and
this in the verification world is coming
up with ways to model the environment
where you the semantics feature space
can be quite large and it's hard to
model that as you know a large feature
vector I'm instead we'd like to give the
user a more programmatic way to write
these models and so what we did was
design a programming language a
probabilistic programming language
called scenic that allows you to just to
define distributions over scene so this
language is currently focused towards
describing 3d scenes of agents along
with models for those agents and of
course it has use cases like you know
just being able to use that as a way to
describe your environment and use it
with a simulator or a renderer to do
data generation but we can also use this
as a language for verification so just
to give you an example here's the code
for a scenic program describing the
scenario of a badly parked car and what
you see down here are from this program
images that we have generated using the
the grand theft
Auto rendering engine so I in the
interest of time I'll skip over what
scenic you know what the syntax is but
the idea is for every scene there's an
ego object in this case it's a car
itself and then we describe locations
that can be picked according to some
distribution right so in this case
there's a curb region and we are picking
a point uniformly at random from that
curb region and we're placing a car at a
badly [ __ ] angle there and so we're
really describing the distribution over
all of these scenes and then the back
end is doing a sampling from that in
order to generate these images and so
we're able to use this to describe any
broad scenarios with with complex
structure like platoons and
bumper-to-bumper traffic but the one
thing I want to talk about here is we
can also use it to debug issues that
come up with deep neural networks so for
instance here's an image that we
synthesized using the the GTA engine of
this car with a racing stripe on it and
then we ran the squeeze net Network on
it and it reported that there are three
cars where there's just one right so
this is a case where and the confidences
are also reasonably high it's hard to
read them and so the quick the question
here is you know why did squeeze net do
that right and similar to the question
that someone asked earlier and so one
thing that we can do now if we have a
programmatic way to generate these
scenes is that we can do you know
systematic debugging by varying
parameters of the scene in
systematically right so we could you
know change the model of the car we can
add noise with respect to its position
we can change the the environment around
the car we can do all of these things in
fact automatically and then see what
happens right and see if the the same
failure scenario comes to comes up again
and in this particular situation we
thought it was the racing stripe and it
turned out that it was none of the the
ones at the bottom here and in fact it
was just the distance between the camera
and the location of the car which I
still don't understand why that was the
problem for for squeezed dead Amy so so
that's the scenic language and what it
allows us to do okay okay so one of the
things we have done over the last year
or so is actually implement all of the
work that I talked about a few more
things in a you know open source toolkit
that we call verify and it has a number
of use cases including you can do things
like property directed parameter
synthesis try to automatically generate
hyper parameters or model parameters so
that once you train your ml model you
the resulting system satisfies some
safety properties so let me give you one
example of something that we've done
with the verify system so this is a
scenario of having an autonomous vehicle
navigate around a stalled vehicle so the
the maroon car on the left is that on
this vehicle it's approaching the stall
vehicle the green one which is
demarcated by a bunch of cones and the
way this works is that the anonymous
vehicle has a camera in front all of
this is done in the we bought simulator
and and this camera image is fed into a
neural network whose job is to estimate
the distance between the camera and
this sort of a you know court
construction site okay and so what the
car is initially doing it's doing lane
keeping and once the neural network
reports that the distance to this sort
of a site is less than 15 meters then
it's going to switch to a lane change
mode and try to navigate around that
okay
and once the lane change did complete
then it goes back to Lane peeping that's
that's what we expect the behavior to be
so what we can do now is we can model
this scenario in scenic describe a
random variable for the look for the
location of that site for the location
of the cones for the orientation of the
cones for the color of the vehicle the
model of the base and all of that stuff
and then we can run our verifier okay
and what I'm going to show you now is a
visualization of what the verifier
search is doing right so initially what
the first simulation you see here is
that it's a it's a correct behavior of
the system okay that the maroon car
correctly navigates around that but now
successively you're going to see more
and more simulations and each one of
them is is this is really showing what
the search of the verification tool is
doing so it tries to find behaviors that
get closer and closer to a violation of
the safety property at some point the
safety property will be by later
okay let me so this is almost okay so
what what what's going on here is very
much the same thing that I talked about
earlier with that the the abstraction
based example okay where we are
combining the system level analysis with
one that is more detailed analysis over
the ML model space so the closer closer
to the point where it actually generates
collisions all right so let me conclude
here so overall I think the what we've
shown is that formal methods can can
certainly help in the design analysis of
deep learning systems and we have a
bunch of open source releases that can
actually integrate well with existing
work and adversity RL ml and there's a
number of other things that I think need
to be done as well
one is to bridge between the simulation
worlds in the real world right so a lot
of the work we're doing here is in the
simulation world and and so we need
advances and things like domain
adaptation to be able to train for the
real world we also need techniques for
runtime assurance so what I mean by that
is anything that we do in design time
verification always makes assumptions
about the operating environment there's
a good chance those assumptions will be
broken at runtime and so what we really
need is ways to monitor those
assumptions and have the system know
that is actually now in an environment
where those assumptions don't hold right
then you have to be able to take
mitigating action all right so I want to
conclude with a few questions and
directions for the theory community that
is motivated by our work the first thing
is I really feel like it will help it
always helps verification when the folks
designing the systems designed them in a
way that makes it easy to verify or
maybe you know eliminates the need even
to do verification of something right so
we really want correct by construction
design and so one of the questions here
is there's all this work on on
adversarial learning in the concrete
feature space can we extend some of the
results to the semantic feature space
the second is there's all this work on
local robustness but I think really the
there's a much broader set of properties
beyond that and one of those one of the
properties beyond local robustness that
we can obtain theoretical guarantees for
the third and this may be a segue into
Zico's talk is it would be great if we
can impose constraints ideally those
that are drawn from formal
specifications at the system level on
the training of the deep neural networks
or into the architecture of the deep
neural networks right without ideally
without sacrificing too much efficiency
I think some of the ideas that have been
proposed recently like semantic loss
functions are a step in that direction
and then finally I talked a little bit
about counter example guided retraining
where you use a verifier to produce
counter examples and then use that to
augment your data set and you can think
of the verifier as an Oracle right that
is answering queries verification
queries and it would be nice to be able
to prove results on the query complexity
for particular domains for particular
classes of systems at least so those are
a few questions for the the theory
community and thank you all for your
attention
[Applause]